what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future okay so recording
audio with a head cold is like one of
the toughest things to do because my
mind is all over the place what we do
here is we pick up with all these
superheroes fighting each other now the
craziest thing about all this is that
this was really just heroes fighting
each other for a little while I mean
there's really not a whole lot to it
it's pretty straightforward but the
other half of this and what Ben does
focuses on is that Ulysses powers are
evolving and his powers are growing it's
not just having visions anymore that
it's about his powers and his visions
becoming a little more complex and in
some ways a little darker the other half
of this is that Ulysses visions are also
getting to the point where he's able to
discern them a little bit better and
differentiate between those visions that
are more likely to happen and those
visions that are least likely to happen
the issue with this though is that as he
goes through and he begins to witness
this fight between all these different
superheroes or Carol Danvers team of
Iron Man's team the guardians of the
galaxy the extraordinary x-men you know
the all-new all-different Avengers so on
and so forth what he does is he has
another vision where he essentially
shows everybody the idea of Miles
Morales killing Steve Rogers and so
because of this is really Carol Danvers
kind of panicking and actually moving
towards the idea of arresting Miles
Morales now this is the point at which
everybody turns against her because
she's talking about arresting a kid it's
one thing if it's an adult it's one
thing if it is somebody who was more
likely to commit a crime but Miles
Morales has done nothing but fight the
good fight he's done nothing but be a
superhero he's not like Hawkeye Brian I
mean Hawkeye was a bad guy before he was
a good guy and even then he wasn't
really like a bad guy per se he was just
kind of a victim of circumstance he was
more or less duped into being a villain
when he first showed up he basically
rectified his errors and became part of
the Avengers but with the rest of these
superheroes looking around and seeing
the Carol Danvers is talking about the
idea of arresting a child for a crime
that he hasn't committed yet Tony Stark
kind of loses it and says look you're
talking about a kid you're talking
you're not arresting a kid and treating
them like they're an adult now in truth
the only person who really should have
anything to say here is Captain America
because he's the one that miles miles
supposedly killed at some point in the
future and so of course Steve Roger
steps up now remember I can't keep
harping this enough because I feel like
it's something easy to forget this is
Hydra Captain America and so while he
puts on this show of hey
look let's be reasonable here you know
let's calm down we have to make sure
we're doing them I think this is all a
show this is all him acting the way he
is for the purpose of creating a rift in
the superhero in the Avengers community
and the way this comes about is when he
basically says hey look there may come a
point where Miles Morales might kill me
but he hasn't done it yet and until he
does it you guys don't need to do
anything and a lot of ways because of
the fact that he's so respected Captain
America's word is law I mean that's just
the way it is when Captain America says
we're going to do things a certain way
people are like okay let's go do it
now Carol Danvers doesn't want to listen
to this Carol Danvers is like no no you
can't just let him go like that
it has it America's like yes I can and
he's going home Thor take him home and
Jane Foster you know basically leaves
and Carol Danvers still wants to arrest
him and so because of that because of
all this because she's basically turned
to this point where nobody really seems
to recognize her for her I guess
everybody's starting to see her for what
she is and somebody who's so dangerous
somebody who's willing to go to whatever
lengths and work to make sure that her
agenda is maintained basically everybody
begins turning against her of course
Tony Stark was already against her but
now Captain America's turning against
her shield is willing to arrest her
you know to chala black panther he
essentially sits down and says I will
follow Captain America to the ends of
the earth Captain America is a man that
I look up to he's a man that I idolized
even if I don't necessarily agree with
everything that he does I do recognize
that the side the Captain America is on
is always the right side and so he says
look I've been around this long enough
I've watched you screw up long enough
I've watched you make mistakes long
enough I'm not doing that anymore I'm
siding with Captain America this kid's
gonna go and I'm I'm a teacher I am no
longer in your corner anymore not only
that our man's team takes off being
humans basically abandoned Carol Danvers
and so it's really just her now at this
point this is where we start to get into
ulysses powers beginning to grow and
beginning to expand because the Inhumans
sit down and try to talk to him and him
is really look we need to talk to you
right now but he's wildly immersed in
everything that's going on in addition
to this all the other members of the
superhero community are trying to figure
out what to do next
this is really just Marvel kind of
setting the stage right I mean this has
been - saying hey look guys after Civil
War - is over we basically get into
Marvel now to point out that's how
things were supposed to happen this was
really kind of like the Secret Wars
Fiasco all over again and the Simpson
Secret Wars are supposed to finish and
then we were supposed to just segue
right into all-new all-different marvel
but because of all the delays the
all-new all-different marvel titles
started coming out before Secret Wars
ended that's basically what's happening
here you know with regards to Civil War
you know in the sense that because of
all the delays civil war two basically
ended before the Marvel now 2.0 titles
came out so for those of you guys who
were getting into like ultimate squared
or those of you guys who are reading
unworthy Thor you know different things
like that uh who were reading you know
the new Iron Man with RiRi Williams a
lot of these things were supposed to
come out after this was finished and so
this should provide some clarity in
terms of where these characters are
coming from something else to note here
though is that RiRi Williams is still a
part of what's going on with regards to
these all-new all-different Avengers
she's kind of a weird situation she's
kind of a mixed bag here in the sense
that she was really figuring out you
know what it is that she was capable of
doing with regards to her makeshift eye
a man's suit while this whole Civil War
2 event was going on that was one of the
major tie-ins of her character with
regards to the backup features and the
invincible Iron Man line of stories
under Brian Michael Bendis but something
else that I want to point your direction
to is that it's Carol Danvers herself
this is why I say that Brian Michael
Bendis is so good at developing
characters because again if you have
this very visceral reaction to carol
danvers listen that you hate her in the
story so far
then Brian Michael Bendis has done his
job and that's really the mark of a good
writer because if you were kind of going
through this and you were like you know
then the story didn't really resonate
with you but if you were anything like
me you hated carol danvers you were mad
as hell with carol danvers you know and
so business was basically doing his job
correctly not only that he shows us that
she is remorseful in her mind's eye she
sees the face of James Rhodes in his
final moments in her mind's eyes she
sees Bruce Banner dead and in her mind
it's all because of her is all because
she basically started all this now she
would never admit that publicly and if
that she refuses to you know when we
have storm in the extraordinary x-men
along with you know Jean Grey and a
handful of others to show up she never
comes out and says look I'm the reason
why all this is going on but a lot of
it's because of the fact that there's no
time to because things are basically
moving a mile a minute where Steve
Rogers had told 4get Miles Morales out
of here and then Miles Morales had Thor
drop him off before he got to his home
he ends up taking off and showing up on
the Capitol Steps in Washington DC which
of course is where Ulysses had the
vision of him killing Captain America
and so this is again Carol Danvers
acting in a reactive way now from here
we jump back to Ulysses and this is
actually what the story gets kind of
cool because now we get ahndrea
sorrentinos art being mingled and with
the art of david marquez now we
something as David Marquez um with this
bit of storytelling here this is
basically Ulysse
kind of leaving this plane of existence
so to speak and actually traversing and
meeting old man Logan now the first
person he encounters is a member of a
hoax family but of course old man Logan
kills it but business doesn't really
give us like an explanation of exactly
when this takes place all we know is
that this seems to be in the old man
Logan universe or universe that is
similar to it but keep in mind when it
comes to those realities when it comes
to the stories the future of the old man
Logan universe when it comes to Days of
Future past those are all alternate
realities at some point along Marvel's
timeline that was the future at some
point along models timeline Days of
Future past was the future until it was
stopped and then it became an alternate
reality at some point along the line old
man Logan was the future until it was
stopped and then it became an alternate
reality that's how that works
and so what Ulysses really seems to be
doing is jumping into these different
realities all of which were at one point
the future of the main Marvel Universe
and so because of this new he's talking
to old man Logan this is basically the
future of the Marvel prime the main
Marvel Universe if the conflict between
Tony Stark and Carol Danvers keeps on
going in his direction the problem with
this is that he doesn't really get a
whole lot of answers here while he's
talking to old man Logan he's like what
led to all this you know where are we
what's going on here old man Logan says
what metre was Tony Stark that happened
Tony Stark pushed her too far
he doesn't say who it was you know and
even when ulysses asked who is it that
you keep referring to when you say he
pushed her too far Logan doesn't respond
he doesn't answer instead he listens
just kind of yanked back to the present
day and he's essentially just kind of
talking to the Inhumans so things are
left a little ambiguous here not only
that we of course have Steve Rogers
heading up to meet with Maz Morales now
this was also covered in the Nick
Spencer Captain America Steve Rogers
story when he was basically
acknowledging the possibility that going
out and see Miles Morales here could
possibly result in his death but because
of the fact that Steve Rogers is a Hydra
agent his goal was to bring down the
superhero community and orchestrate the
fall of superheroes in and of themselves
allowing Hydra to basically take its
place the problem with this is that in
the midst of all this exposition between
Carol Danvers and Maz Wiles the Steve
Rogers we suddenly have Tony Stark
making his appearance with his war
machine on were released some more
advanced iteration of his armor the
problem with this is that while Carol
Danvers and Tony Stark are fighting one
another the indication here seems to be
thick Harold Danvers basically kills
Tony Stark now that's not necessarily
the case and the system she doesn't
armored but the reason why Carol Danvers
is able to do this because because
remember she's still binary now this is
something that a lot of people don't
know about when it comes to Carol
Danvers and I want to touch on this for
a second so way back in the day when she
first showed up she was just a woman who
was part of the Air Force there was
nothing special about her but she was
enamored with marvel of the Kree who
operated as Captain Marvel because of
this there came a point where she was
basically exposed to the psych magnetron
and her desire to be the equivalent of
Captain Marvel resulted in her
developing the powers that she had so
she went forward as Miss Marvel's there
was really kind of the crux of her that
happened for quite some time but Marvel
really lost the ability to do anything
special with her because I couldn't find
any compelling stories now eventually
she was rolled over to the x-men under
Chris Claremont and he basically made
her this person that had the ability to
absorb all different kinds of energy and
then use those energy for her own ends
energy projection and hand strength so
on and so forth and so she wasn't really
a mutant per se so much as somebody who
just had these cosmic level powers to a
degree and so because of that following
the whole era of her being binary under
Chris Claremont as part of the expand
franchise eventually she was rolled back
over and the binary element of her
character was rarely ever seen but it
was something that still existed and
that's why if you go through and you
looked at carol danvers in like the
1990s going into the early 2000s even up
to the present day every once in a while
you would see her used energy blast
because that's something she was capable
of doing she doesn't use it very often
but she does from time to time now
having said that and focusing again back
on Ulysses his continued experiences are
really just tied directly into watching
all these events unfold and again these
possible futures the problem with this
is that as Carol Danvers and Tony Stark
continue to fight one another ulysses
visions eventually lead him to the
ethereal plane to beyond the realm of
normal existence not only that he
basically grabs the mind of Carol
Danvers Nova Miles Morales all these
different heroes and basically says here
are all the futures that I see here all
the things that could happen you know
there's futures were monsters run
everything there's futures where the
x-men have taken over the world there
are future is where Steve Rogers was
killed by Maha's miles there are all
these different features out there Days
of Future past
Ultron takes over everything there's all
these different realities that exist and
then suddenly he moves beyond the storm
a plane of existence and he encounters
eternity now something I want to clarify
here because a lot of people have been
asking this question about Marvel when
it came to the Kimberley
idea of eternity being chained in the
ultimates line of stories eternity isn't
changed in this story he's not in Chains
there's a reason for that and Ultimates
squared I think it was Galactus actually
revealed that the Eternity hasn't
changed is the multiversal eternity and
that was something that had never really
been explored before it had to a degree
mention maybe like once or twice but it
was nothing Marvel actually went with
instead all they ever said was well
every universe has its own version of
eternity what ultimate squared revealed
is that there is a multiversal attorney
there's one eternity that represents the
multiverse you know one eternity that
represents all the different universes
in the multiverse that eternity is
changed but all the other eternities
from within each universe which are like
these child units so to speak they're
still able to operate accordingly so
again it's kind of a weird situation
with regards to Marvel in terms of what
they're doing where the cosmic entities
is a constant example of the left hand
not knowing what the right hand is doing
and it's one of the reasons why despite
it being all new in all different
continuity errors still reign supreme
but the fact remains here that in this
climactic battle which does kind of feel
a bit rushed we basically have Tony
Stark who's kind of left unconscious and
while he's not necessarily dead he seems
to be in this weird kind of catatonic
state now then this gives almost no
explanation as to why this is all he
really has be sick is that well it
totally sucks been experimenting on
himself and beast is afraid to do
anything because he doesn't know what
kind of impact it will have and so
there's kind of leaving Tony Stark in
this weird catatonic state now we know
by virtue of what Tony Stark has done
that he's basically made himself a
computer projection we know this in the
Ironman stories and an infamous Iron Man
when he basically starts talking to dr.
doom when dr. doom becomes Iron Man we
also know this in the new Iron Man
stories when he appears to riri Williams
as her new AI or at least as the AI for
her new suit and so Tony Stark really
seems to be kind of shunted off to the
background right now and he may come
back at some point in time but this is
basically setting the stage for Tony
Stark to be removed from the position of
Iron Man for Doctor Doom to take up the
traditional Iron Man role and then Ruby
Williams to have Tony Stark being her AI
for when she becomes the Iron Man
character but again things just kind of
wrap up relatively fast I mean there's
not a whole lot of exposition here
there's a lot of questions that are kind
of left open-ended in terms of the fact
that no one knows that Captain America
is still a Hydra agent we don't really
know what direction things are gonna go
on with she-hulk but it's really kind of
the situation where everybody's dealing
with the fallout of civil war - in their
own ways again you know really will
becoming Iron Man she-hulk is still
pissed off the Bruce banners dead
Captain America still plotting for Hydra
to take over the world
Miles Morales is still trying to deal
with the realization that he was almost
arrested for a future possibility of him
killing Captain America is people really
just kind of coming to terms with their
own place in the superhero community
knowing the possible futures that could
exist for them well the story ultimately
wraps up with some animatic phrase about
Carol Danvers saying that she has some
ideas for the future but again we don't
really know what this means but again
this story was kind of rushed in a lot
of different ways especially when it
came to the ending it really does
reflect the notion that it was a story
written for the purpose I just kind of
being a cash grab on the main civil war
movie that was coming out - Captain
America Civil War but if you guys are
new here to calmly explain and you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys like this make sure
you drop a like and yeah leave a comment
down below because I'm kind of curious
I'm sure this is going to get some very
mixed reactions but leave a comment down
below let me know what you guys thought
about Civil War - did you love it did
you hate it do you not really care I'm
kind of curious you know as to where
people stand but any event yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you